The mystery of the Hulk's sizzled right arm
in Avengers: Endgame has finally been answered.
The reason the Green Goliath was injured so
badly using the Infinity Stones while, if
you'll recall, Thanos was not is simple.
According to co-director Joe Russo, it was
a purposeful choice to continue highlighting
the magnitude of the Mad Titan's strength,
as well as to display how potent the Infinity
Stones are when used.
In the film, well-adjusted and emotionally
stable Professor Hulk, a merging of the brains
and mild temperament of Bruce Banner with
the green, super-strong physique of the Hulk,
wielded the Infinity Stones to bring back
the lives lost in Avengers: Infinity War.
Of course, his act of service didn't come
without a heavy penalty: Hulk experienced
substantial cosmic charring up his entire
right arm and part of his neck.
By the end of the movie, the arm was rendered
pretty much useless.
Since he's presented as one of the most powerful
characters in the Marvel Cinematic Universe,
it came as a surprise to the audience — and
even his fellow Avengers — that Hulk took
such a substantial hit using the Infinity
Stones — especially since he was deemed
most likely to survive the impact of using
Tony Stark's Infinity Gauntlet 2.0 to channel
their power.
"You saw what those stones did to Thanos.
They almost killed him.
None of you could survive."
"How do we know you will?"
"We don't."
Fans will recall that in Infinity War, Thanos
used the stones to snap half of all life in
the universe out of existence, with relatively
little injury to himself — though his Infinity
Gauntlet was heavily damaged in that first
usage.
It was only when he used the Stones again
— to destroy them, this time — that it
really took a toll, as he emerged from the
experience with a noticeable hobble and some
pretty bad damage to his Gauntlet arm.
Russo explained that it was important for
the filmmakers to revisit how the Hulk, for
all his incredible power, paled compared to
Thanos.
He explained:
"We know how powerful Thanos is by his quick
defeat of the Hulk in Infinity War, so this
is an incredibly painful experience, to put
on the gauntlet that controls the universe.
It permanently damages the most powerful beings
and some of the most powerful creatures in
these movies, and very few people can actually
put that on and survive."
Marvel Studios' head of visual development
Ryan Meinerding also explained that in earlier
development, they considered giving Hulk a
more substantial injury in the form of physically
shrivelling his arm, but ultimately abandoned
the idea due to technical problems presented
in later fight sequences.
Meinerding revealed:
"When Hulk brings everybody back with a snap
using the Stark gauntlet, they wanted Hulk
to have paid a severe price for doing it.
The idea of his arm being shriveled and messed
up was where they were going with it initially,
and...
I pitched that basically when his arm gets
shriveled, he just rips his sleeve off and
turns it into a sling to allow him to fight
later on in the film and not have that asymmetry
be something that was too odd.
In the end, they worked it out fine in the
movie without that concept."
Endgame makes a big deal of exacting cost;
it's fair to say that Thor and Hulk are diametrically
opposed examples of the best and worst ways
to cope with the fallout of Infinity War …
"Oh my god!
Oh my god!"
"It's so good to see you!"
"Come here you little rascal!"
"No, no, I'm good!
I'm good!"
… so in lending gravity to Hulk's decision
to use the Stark gauntlet, it would have made
no sense to have him make angst-ridden soliloquies
like Thor.
Hulk's grasp on the situation, however, did
not suddenly make him more physically able
than he was in Infinity War, and it would
have cheapened both movies to suddenly grace
him with Thanos-level strength.
One of the main themes of Avengers: Endgame
is sacrifice.
The film demonstrates over and over again
that the only way to be victorious over "inevitable"
defeat is through cooperation, teamwork, and
costly actions that exact a terrible personal
price.
The Avengers' strategy for reversing the Snap
was an incredibly complex one, and every action
had consequences.
It just so happened that some of those consequences
were more painful than others.
Endgame's doling out of terrible prices for
each small victory was poetic and effective.
It illustrated that even for Earth's Mightiest
Heroes, reversing an action as drastic as
the Snap would truly require them to be willing
to do say it with us whatever it takes.
In a universe where anything can happen and
be undone as is convenient, what makes us
care is characterization, and characters who
actually have to suffer before achieving success.
In a film with stakes as high as Endgame,
that suffering comes swift and hard even if
you're the Incredible Hulk.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the Marvel
Cinematic Universe are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.